wait i said number one number one trevor
lawrence that would be a shock if he
goes number two number one to the
jaguars number two
zach wilson to the jets and then he's
got we talked last hour about this mac
jones or
trey lance who's going third to the
49ers
peter says mac jones i would tend to
agree with him at this point
and uh and look
after that who knows what's gonna happen
that's when the draft begins with the
falcons at number four
and peter's got kyle pitts uh
going to the falcons not trey lance
which some think they may do chris
yeah right i mean that that's gonna be
the the one i think everyone perks up a
little bit here
i mean the 49ers thing again like i said
at the top of you know the show today
i would still expect it to be mac jones
but the fact that you
hear this much conversation out there
right now
and there's nothing to benefit the 49ers
i i gotta think that there's an outside
chance for trey lance in this
conversation
but if i'm atlanta sitting there at four
mike i take pits
i do i mean we're in 2021 like we've
talked about matt ryan still got at
least two or three good years at least
in them
so i just don't think you look for the
quarterback of the future right now when
you got a guy where you go
damn you know he can still play some
pretty high level football for us
i the one he can hold at number 11 for a
couple more years i think
yeah right if we can keep him there
right just on the outside of chris sims
top ten just right around there i agree
you'll be right there perfect spot for
him but here's the other ass
here's the other one i think that's
that's like interesting in there is that
that cincinnati pick right i mean that
cincinnati pick to me is very
interesting and i could certainly you
know a lot of people think it's penne
sewell right
they peter's got jamar chase i
tend to think it might be jamar chase
too you know again it there's a lot of
good offensive alignment in the draft
there's no doubt they should be able to
get one at the top of the second
you know they could do it the other way
around like we talked about last week
where they could go
offensive lineman at five and get a
pretty good receiver you know at the top
of the second
but i don't know if it's gonna be a
special one not a special one like jamar
chase
who's really like i'd have a hard time
thinking he's not a special
he's kind of a can't miss prospect so i
i could see that mike i mean what's your
thought about them going kind of like
you know just weapons galore there with
a jamar chase at five
i i have long believed that the bengals
who are
notoriously small c conservative yeah
they were gonna go with penne sewell at
left tackle they had the bad experience
four years ago
with john ross the ninth overall pick
the receiver the fast guy they took out
of washington
that didn't work out and last week
we played the clip of joe burrow
talking to chris collinsworth and
richard sherman about
where he comes down on what they should
do at number five and he was very
diplomatic he was very tactful and
sharing williams caught on and said you
know what if he really wanted jamar
chase
is his college teammate he's going to
get a call from dramaar chase saying
dude what the hell you should be out
there pushing for me like kyle murray
pushed for cd lamb last year but maybe
joe's playing it cool
joe's being coy joe doesn't want to blow
up what he's got working behind the
scenes maybe he is working on folks
to take jamar chase just like justin
herbert wants to be reunited with penny
sewell
you know when you already know the guy
it makes your life a lot easier it's not
some new personality you have to get
experienced
with you know how receivers can be at
times they can be a little difficult at
times
and it's the guy he's already built the
relationship with we've seen how it
works i guess it wouldn't stun me
on the surface but it would surprise me
that the bengals would do the thing that
isn't the safe thing the safe thing is
sewell the riskier thing is chase
yeah no i hear you but i think there's
enough chatter in league circles
to think that this is a real debate in
cincinnati right now
you know i i've been told by some people
close to the situation that this is
this is a little bit of a you know i
don't want to say a civil
war or anything like that but the
organization this is a real conversation
going on there at number five right now
between chase and sewell so that would
be interesting it really will be
i mean you know you're right you said a
lot of good things there there's no
doubt about it i
think joe burrows not that type of guy
he's just not that type of guy that's
going to put anything out there like
that
and i think at base level he's probably
going to be happy with either one
either one is going to help his life out
greatly
but man that chase you know you can
almost take a little bit of uh
and i know the offensive line's not set
up but when you get cincinnati and then
you throw in jamar chase with t
higgins and boyd and joe mixon you start
to go
whoa that's kind of a dangerous unit
there you start to think like
maybe they could go mahomes kansas city
chiefs type you know
explosive offense that's the interesting
angle that jumps out to it about me
to me here's what boils down to one guy
helps you get rid of the ball faster the
other guy lets you hold on to the ball a
little bit right
either way burrow's got bigger issues
he's got to get that knee healthy
and it's six or one half a dozen the
other chase is either gonna
pump up the receiving core or sewell is
going to
help joe burrow avoid the kind of hits
he was taking last year look at that
let's see how that goes yeah yeah i mean
those are they had a special connection
i you know this guy this is where i just
go
you know again like you know jamar che i
mean uh you know
like you're talking about the the
receiver who who ran the fast time they
drafted
john ross john ross yeah he was scary
there's no doubt
but that was a speed projection type guy
this guy we saw in the sec
against the best teams dominate
as a sophomore he was the best receiver
in college football
like he'd be one of those guys where
you'd go uh
we could have broke the rules for him
and let him go out
he was ready after two years that's how
talented he is and i'm sure that's
what's giving the the bengals some
you know some fits right behind the the
the scenes right now
so under this scenario you've got justin
fields and trey lance
slipping past five they split past six
they slipped past
seven and peter has the panthers taking
justin
fields at eight we talked last hour
about what
what are they gonna do with sam darnold
they got him under contract this year
the option
deadline for 2022 is may 3.
he has them having both trey lance and
justin fields
at their disposal and taking fields how
big of a surprise would that be if that
happened i would be shocked
i mean absolutely shocked i really would
be i don't even know what to say there
first off
i just don't think that's the way they
want to play you know carolina wants to
throw the ball
that's why they signed teddy bridgewater
and they got sam darnold
and i think they were interested in mac
jones at number eight
you know they want a guy that's going to
drop back and dissect you and pick you
apart
that does not say justin fields to me
right now at this point of his career
in fact he's the riskiest one out of all
the quarterbacks to be able to do that
by far the riskiest one so that's where
i just
that would be shocking to me i just
don't see that happening
i really don't i i uh so uh i don't know
what to say i'd like to make a wager
with peter or somebody like that to go
like there's no way but
we'll see uh but you think if it's if
it's
lance and fields on the board and they
go quarterback do you think it's more
likely fields than lance
no i think no i think i think lance has
passed up
fields in just about everybody's eyes
that i know in the nfl
anybody i've talked to you know people
who i know who know
somebody whatever it is i believe lance
is in front of fields on most teams
draft boards i do
because of the issues with fields those
some of those issues we've talked about
are they've scared teams and i know some
teams that certainly go i just don't
know
if we can fix or you can fix some of
those issues as far as
uh what justin fields has thrown the
football there so
we'll see this is where it's gonna get
interesting part of the draft but i
would think ultimately
carolina's gonna be looking to trade
down at number eight that would be
what my money's on back at six
yeah i want to just point out one thing
peter has jalen waddle from alabama
the dolphins i think that's that's the
pick if it is between waddling devonta
smith i also
think chris if jamar chases on the board
at six
yeah the dolphins are more inclined to
take waddle which would open the door
for the the if the bengals want to get
cute
it would open the door for them to slide
down but we know they don't do that they
just go ahead and take the guy
that they want they're not gonna play
games right they're not gonna they're
not gonna experience
that hour or so of holy crap
are we to get our guy are we going to
get our guy did we did we outsmart
ourselves but
there is a path to them getting chase or
really sewell
you know that's another way to make the
decision let someone else make it for
you
yeah let's trade back a few spots and
we'll take whoever's left
yeah no you're they're they could play
that game
certainly uh but it's a risky game to
play
it definitely is and hey that that that
waddle
conversation at number six that that's
interesting i mean it really is i like
waddle
i don't think he's in the class of jamar
chase and davonte smith i think he's a
notch down
but i do know there's people in the nfl
that look at him as being like the top
guy there
so that'd be interesting to see with the
miami dolphins they have a real need at
that position
so either way i would think they're
going some sort of pass catcher there at
number six i would be surprised if if
that wasn't the case
peter does have as he suggested on
friday on this program five quarterbacks
going in the top
nine that is unbelievable trey lance
would land to the broncos under
peter's formulation and then you get
into the cowboys
the first defensive player off the board
patrick certain the alabama
corner uh and that's that's
the safer pick i know jc horn is doing
everything he can to try to pump himself
up as the better option but chris as you
say all along
you got to have straightaway speed you
got to be able to recover when the
receiver runs past you and you believe
certain has that
in a better supply than jc horn yeah
definitely i mean i still even
questioned that with certain but
you know i understand certain being the
number one corner in the draft i do
i mean it's clean he's got everything
you want he fits what they would want to
do in dallas as far as that coverage all
that
you know the jc horn thing everybody you
know that's one of those where it's like
everybody has philadelphia taking jc
horn to where it's like on my own mock
trap
i'm putting them there too because it's
one of those things where it's just like
it seems like everybody knows something
so i don't i don't know but yeah
you know jc horn yeah you know my
thoughts on them there's a lot to like
but that top end speed is a question for
me and
and to me i'm not taking a corner in the
top 15 who i don't feel like can be on
an island with the elite receivers in
football
i guess if uh if everybody thinks that
the eagles are taking uh
jc horn that says somebody's got a look
at jeffrey lurie's draft board
what about what about you what do you
what is this number nine though i mean
that's that to me you know the
number nine with the trey lance thing
that's that's right
that's gonna be interesting i mean
the ongoing quest by the broncos to get
a quarterback and perfect fangio hey vic
fangio's
pink slip was signed when they hired a
new gm
because as i've said time and again
every gm when he becomes a gm he just
doesn't show up as a gm
he's been working in the league for
years he's got a list of the coaches
that he wants to hire when he becomes a
gm just like bob quinn
wanted matt patricia in detroit you've
always got the guys you want and unless
coincidentally vic fangio's at the top
of george payton's list
vic fandue is already on borrowed time
so peyton's not going to draft a guy
that's going to help fangio save his ass
if anything he's going to draft a guy
that he thinks is going to help the team
long term and also
it buys a little time you get a year
with fangio you hire your coach next
year
right and uh and that's just the way it
works that that's why i'm a firm
believer
in never having this cockeyed we kept
the coach we fired the gm we fired the
gm we kept the coach we fired the co no
fire them both or keep them both you got
to have them on the same page and
walking through the door george payton's
not gonna be on the same page with vic
fangio so
that doesn't surprise me at all they
desperately want a quarterback
desperately and wouldn't it be great if
peyton could show right out of the gates
that he knows how unlike his predecessor
to pick a quarterback in the draft he
ain't picking brock osweiler's not
picking paxton lynch
he's he's going to get now he better be
right but
i could see i could see george payton
want to do that just to prove right away
that the problem solved this is the guy
who's been in in the business for 20
years not the guy who just showed up and
was handed the keys like john elway was
10 years ago
in denver yeah no i i know this is to me
another interesting pick and certainly
i'm i'm very intrigued with what
denver will do there at number nine you
know i mean i mean listen again i
i like trey lance a lot of the top end
talent it's raw
and you're gonna have to play a certain
way you know early on
you know and i do think you'll have to
rely on the running a little bit which i
also want to go back
all those good receivers and they're
going to have to have a a quarterback a
little bit more
with a running predicated offense you
know the way their team's built
you know the rawness of drew lock now
you're going to have two raw
quarterbacks there
you know i mean the den broncos are one
of those teams it's kind of close
that's where i i for me just looking at
them as a 2021
entity just by that itself i just go
man defense top tennis in football
offense good old line receivers galore
like could have a superstar air show
with the
receivers you know and then so i just
look at them going they could be one of
those teams that pops on the scene this
year
and do you really want to do it with a
rookie quarterback that's where i go
like
the drew lock teddy bridgewater drew
lock jimmy garoppolo thing makes a lot
of sense for me
uh as far as their from their standpoint
as far as where they are right now as a
football
team peter made an observation today i
just want to press pause and get your
thoughts on this
he thinks it's going to be very
difficult for other teams in the top 10
to trade
out yes and trade down because of
everything the 49ers gave up to move
from 12
to 3. do you i have mixed feelings about
that because i think
each trade is its own thing and you're
ultimately trading for the player you're
not trading for the slot
yeah but uh i i don't know what do you
think do you think we're gonna see fewer
trades because the 49ers blew the curve
to move up nine spots
i don't think so i don't think that's
going to affect anything you know again
what we don't know too
is like what was being talked about at
that pick number three too
do we know that the 49ers weren't you
know uh
you know bargaining with somebody else
out there to get the number three spot
so that could have drove that up another
pick or so right
if there was a let's say carolina was
interested and they were getting the
number three
that could have arose that price so
that's where i don't think you can just
say it's apples to apples to move up
like that
here would be my thing mike just my take
you take the quarterbacks out of this
conversation
would i want to go because you hear like
everyone wants to trade down
everyone wants to trade down everyone
wants to kick picks back in the next
year
the problem is is who is there to trade
up for
that's the big thing this year you know
after you get past a few guys
i don't know if any of these guys are
the type of entities where you just look
at to where
teams are like oh we got to get to 14 to
get that guy
you know as we've talked about some of
the best players in the draft or the
covet opt-outs or the
the guys that have the the medical
concerns and they're not going to people
aren't going to trade up in the top 10
or 15 to get those type of guys so
that's where it's going to be
interesting to see how this all kind of
plays out on thursday night
and the last time we saw a gigantic
return
in the top 10 was that
rg3 trade nine years ago and i'm looking
at the top ten picks now there was
movement
there was significant movement on draft
day right after
that so it's yeah you're you're
investing for the player
the the challenge always is though
finding someone who
will trade up and i think one of the
dynamics this year
the reluctance to part ways with 2022
picks because those picks relatively
speaking more valuable because as of
next year
presumably hopefully teams will be able
to have private workouts there'll be a
scouting combine there'll be
visits things will be normal next year
not this
this half full glass of scouting that'll
be the full cup and they'll be able to
to have more information and more
confidence when they use their picks
making the 2022 picks more valuable
making teams less likely
to want to give them up to move up in a
year where it's more of a crapshoot i
think that
is as big of a factor as anything i i
agree i i do i mean i think that that's
why it's
i mean i'm i'm expecting one of the more
fun action-packed controversial drafts
we've seen
just between all the things going into
this like you said
teams looking to trade down because of
the the 2022 pick situation and they're
feeling that there's going to be more
information
all of that type of stuff teams i think
are going to be a little bit misinformed
on a year like this
you might see teams reach for you know
certain positions in this draft because
you know there's there's not a premium
of guys at all positions
uh you know again i'll bring up the
jalen phillips
the maya make the jalen phillips the
miami dolphins pass rusher he's one of
those guys you would trade up for
he's a top 10 pick i don't think there's
any way he's going to go in the top 10
because he's got to you know the
concussion is same with caleb farley
you know where does he go i go back to
that he's he's a top five pick
in any other year but he's got a medical
issue so i
mean between the quarterbacks the covet
opt-outs
uh and all these other story lines we've
talked about i i think
thursday night's gonna be a blast to
watch yeah you mentioned jalen phillips
the dolphins taking him at 18 under
peter's mock draft and then another guy
that you really like caleb farley all
the way to 17 to your guy
john gruden taking the defensive guy
with that pick but hey
if farley lasts that long if he sneaks
past the vikings at 14 the patriots at
15
uh then you know makes sense for john
gruden to jump on him that's definitely
an area of need
no no doubt i mean i would think so the
other guy that
i just you know with the raiders and of
course just knowing them a little bit
yeah you know they could use a corner
because they're not great there but man
they drafted a first round corner last
year they drafted a second round corner
of the year before that
they drafted a first round safety in
that same year
you know i mean how many draft picks are
we gonna use on corners
right at some point some of these guys
just gotta play and play better
you know that's where i just don't know
if i will get behind that i mean to make
it make sense the one i look at with the
raiders at 17
to just go the other option just why
we're talking raiders
is jeremiah wusu cora moa right this is
gus
bradley that's seattle defense they want
fast linebackers like a darius leonard
or
fred warner right mike to me that would
be a guy where i could see
you know that being another option for
the raiders it's gonna i would think
it's gotta be defense they need help on
defense badly it's crappy there
in in oakland or in las vegas excuse me
so
i wouldn't be shocked to see farley ku
sukuramoa
maybe even a top edge pass rusher if
they love to go there right now because
they don't have that either
five first round picks in the last two
drafts and and
look josh jacobs has been very good um
he didn't necessarily have to be a first
round pick henry ruggs
jury is way way out he's got the
potential but you know
they really need to hit jury's out on
all of them they need to hit jury's out
of all except for jacobs like you said
yeah
you know i mean you know cleveland
farrell i mean the jury is out with
colin farrell he wasn't worth the number
four pick we know that so
yeah this is a this is a big draft for
for the raiders to help their football
team
you mentioned awu sakuramoa peter has
the browns trading up from 26 to 21 to
get him and andrew barry the gem of the
team
explained on friday to reporters they
have a lot of flexibility they ca
like everybody else as we've said trade
up down or use their pick they can do
that
everyone can do that except the jaguars
who can't trade up but
if the browns trade out around one this
is a very real dynamic
right when you're hosting the draft you
have a lot of pissed off cleveland
people who've been
sitting around all night long to see
what the browns are going to do at
you can't trade out a round one i i
you're like you're right
you know i i saw that a little bit this
weekend with andrew barry's quotes and
like
saying how he wouldn't be a fan favorite
if that happened no you won't
i could say no not only will you be
hearing boos
or whatever else then what's going to be
worse is they're going to put
under the microscope whatever you trade
it away and who you pick there is going
to be even
magnified even more because it's like
hey wait you screwed up our draft night
and now who did you screw it up for it
better work out so
uh but i could in peter's scenario there
again
that makes sense just like we were
talking about with the raiders it's the
same defensive scheme
the cleveland browns are running it's
the seattle scheme joe woods came from
the 49ers who run that
so they have a real need for that kind
of guy
that speed linebacker so from from
peter's standpoint there
that's certainly logical i get that all
the way and you know when you've got a
great team
like the browns now do and it's still
hard to get your mouth
to say that yeah the brain sends the
message the browns
browns have a great team the brown
they're in a position where this is a
gravy pick for them there isn't some oh
my god you've got to address this
you're absolutely positively no they're
they're in pretty good shape and they
can
and that's something that andrew barry
said they're they're in a spot where all
the draft picks they can get guys that
are going to develop
you know this is the way it's supposed
to go you have a good team in place good
strong nucleus
and you develop behind them and then as
you make the strategic decisions to let
some of those guys leave via free agency
or trade them or whatever
you've got guys that you can put into
those and you just keep that conveyor
belt going
right right no i i mean i'm i'm with you
you're right so
they got a hell of a roster and
that position you know maybe another
defensive tackle
the only things you can really look at
on their roster to go
okay we need some improvement there
everything else they've done a
phenomenal job they really have i mean
cleveland's sitting pretty so it'd be
cool to see what they do
what do you think about the patriots
15th overall selection
166 pounds soaking wet devonta smith i i
i just have a hard time thinking devonte
smith is going to be
on the board still at that point you
know i
i just know from from my own studies and
just people i've talked to around the
nfl
mike people are enamored with devonte
smith
now i mean i know the weight thing is
real and
like we talked about it last week a
little the scary thing is just like if
he gets hurt people can be like i told
you so
but that's the only thing there's
nothing to make you believe that
i mean i i hear i've had some coaches
tell me like man devonte smith is as
good as any receiver i've ever evaluated
so that's where i just don't see him
being around at that point
uh but that would be ooh that would be
interesting you add him to that offense
now with the two receivers they signed
him free agency
and that o-line and cam newton that
could be scary that could be scary speed
coming
out of new england i look at it this way
there's got to be somebody who loves the
guy enough before
15. or somebody after 15 who loves him
enough
to spring up and get him i would think
he'd be one of those guys i agree
i agree mike that this could be one of
those guys if he's hanging around at
eight or nine or ten
that you see a guy that there's that's a
truly a
legitimate trade-up type talent i think
your point right is real there
people are going to look at it and go
man the route running the feet
you know when the ball's in his hands
and the pure speed and play-making
ability of the guy it's it's off the
charts good
so it's a good thing it's a good thing
that the chiefs
have already traded their first round
pick oh man because i wouldn't
my god yes could you
tyree kill devonte smith and mikol
hardman
good lord man that would be fun to watch
there's no doubt uh but that i'd be
excited to see the patriots get devonte
smith
i just have a hard time thinking he'll
be there at 15.
you know i'm starting to have all sorts
of crazy ideas and thoughts about how
the chiefs could get devonta smith but
i'm just gonna
i'm not i'm not gonna entertain that
rabbit hole because i'm now fascinated
by
the the possibility of him and patrick
mahomes being on the same field together
i'd never considered it until just now
well it's not going to happen so don't
worry they're they're they're they've
made their bed they went with a huge
giant left tackle instead so that's what
they're going with
the the other thing i don't like about
devonta smith going to the patriots at
15. that means the vikings would pass on
him at 14. i don't know how i feel about
that
yeah i know but you guys need him you
don't need them
especially the way you guys run your
offense and well
i mean let's talk about your vikings for
a second i mean i gotta think it's pass
rusher or
offense alignment right one of the two i
mean i guess if you made me bet money
with that offense and you know you got
clint kubiak as the new oc and
everything like that i would think they
got to go with the offensive lineman the
best one available there at that point
yeah peter has a lehigh vera tucker from
usc
yeah flexibility garden tackle yeah
there needs to be a guy that can do the
the zone blocking he can do that that
makes sense
so that that that's what they need it's
not a sexy pick but it's an
infrastructure pick and that's what the
vikings need because we know with pair
cousins he can run the play that's
called
and if the play that's called doesn't
work that's the end of it so
with rally reef gone i'm just he loves
him
he loves him the needs are you know the
thing about the draft
it the skill position players are the
ones who get the people most excited
but it is the infrastructure guys that
lay the foundation for a team
to be great you've got to build from the
inside out but that just isn't
interesting no it's not when when draft
knight rolls around what's interesting
is devonta smith and the quarterbacks
and
uh peter has two running backs i that's
i talked last week
you don't think there's going to be any
he's got two going in round one
starting with the steelers nadia harris
from alabama
hey i i saw that and you know i had to
do my own mock draft and i'm not going
to lie
i thought about the steelers with travis
atn
from clemson as being a possibility but
yeah i decided not to i i mean
you know i i understand that from the
steelers standpoint
and all that but man that you know again
i just
first off i don't really think any of
these running backs are first-round type
talents
other than atn and i think that's
borderline and really with the steelers
too
i mean as we've discussed they got
offensive line issues i gotta think
they're thinking some sort of offensive
lineman there at 24
that could be plug and play this year so
uh they could wait to the second or
third round to get a running back uh
but but that's interesting thought i'd
be shocked to see if any of these
running backs go i will
i've been saying that they need a frank
o'hara's type
they need harris was the 13th overall
pick
in 1972. i'm looking now the steelers
have used first round picks on running
backs more than a few times over the
course of their
their existence but it's been a while i
think the last one
when's the last time in 1989 yeah yeah
tim tim worley oh richard mendenhall
first round oh
2008 the last year they won a super bowl
maybe maybe there's
maybe there's some some kismet there
maybe you take a running back in the
first round now and it works out the way
it did when they took richard mendenhall
out of illinois
back in 2008 i remember that now so look
the steelers are not afraid to draft for
need and they're not afraid to trade up
to get the guy they want
right and i i don't rule them out
if if one of these quarterbacks makes it
past
10 and starts to slide
if they really love the guy and they're
not going to tell us ahead of time i
wouldn't rule the steelers
out from making a move to try to go
ahead and get there their guy that's
going to take the baton from ben
roethlisberger in 2020
what happens when you don't have a
franchise quarterback you go 20 years
with a revolving door of mediocrity
i still know how they got to a super
bowl between the terry bradshaw and ben
roethlisberger years i i
i mean i i hear you i think if there's a
like one of those quarterbacks maybe a
lance or fields falls
i would think pittsburgh's got to think
about that to a degree i do
i guess the only thing that would make
me think no with that is just like
you know again it goes back to like a
little bit of our tom brady conversation
to where like
hey they got big ben you know and i know
hey that'll be a tough balance but it's
just like do they want to go all in on
big ben
one more year and get something that's
going to help the team right now this
second
that's the decision the steelers will
have to make i think when
they made the decision to keep
roethlisberger around it did skew toward
going all in
i'd be very very surprised if they would
use their first round pick and or future
assets on
a quarterback now far more likely i
think
they stay where they are and see which
running backs there
and and try to add to this
this thing they've convinced themselves
they can do which is
go back to zero and zero and start
winning game after game after game like
they did last year and not have it all
fall apart down the stretch
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports